what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday
the 19th of july the joint is brought to
you by
my favorite manscaped summer is here
and your uncle joey's getting in the
pool in fact i might get in the pool
today
anyway manscape is great and i'll tell
you why i like them
because your balls will be [__] fresh
and clean and they don't stink like
[__]
10 dead [__] cubans and then you know
just i could
[__] go on forever why i love
manscape you gotta trim
you gotta take care of your [__]
helmet women see that [__] at the pool
your nut pops out you know how many
times my nut has popped out at the pool
you want it to be shaving you want that
punching bag to look good
that's where manscape comes in and
manscape just revealed
their fourth generation performance
package they got the first
new and improved lawnmower 4.0 trimmer
listen i give you a bunch of marketing
[__] but listen the bottom line is the
skin
safe technology it's designed to protect
your [__] nuts and your dick bag
even my long balls don't get caught in
these [__] gears
and the blades are sharp enough to cut
through [__] white hairs
like butter you set the length of your
trim from one to four
and if you're old school [__] it they
even put a [__] light on it so you
could [__] do it at night in the dark
by yourself
before you give her a stab in the closet
if you're into the closet
i don't give a [__] and they got a
travel lock on it
so you throw this in your weekend bag
and you're set for any [__] situation
do me a favor
what i'm gonna do for you today is get
20 off and free worldwide shipping
by going to manscape.com joey
we're going to throw in the whole
[__] package because you don't stop
at the nuts we got to get the weed
whacker to trim up your nose and ear
hairs
with 9 000 rpm motors listen
i got boogers coming out of me since the
[__] 80s with this [__] weed
whacker
but i'll get the whole package the crop
reviver the crop preserver get the
[__] undies they send you
get the bag get the whole thing it
starts today
20 off and free worldwide shipping by
going to manscape.com
joey again that's 20 off and free
worldwide shipping by going to
manscape.com
joey no more stinky heads get your dick
to be a [__] model beautiful
with manscape the joint is also brought
to you by
c b d lion
i [__] love it especially now i went
to the pool the other day
i got a little sun burnt it was kind of
itchy at night
guess what i put some cbd lion on it the
extra strength
[__] cream tremendous no more [__]
itchy it went away you see what i'm
saying
cbd lion comes in a variety whether you
want to smoke the hemp flower
the gummy bears the tablets
i mean we got it all for you you could
smoke it
you could [__] bathe in it with the
bath balls
you could rub it on however you want cbd
lion's got you covered
go to cbd line read the third party lab
results
and get back to me [__] and that's
it
hold on let me light this [__] thing
right here for you
and let's get this thing going right now
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
so
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 19th of july it's a
beautiful
[__] day to be alive holy [__] first
off i want to thank you guys for
supporting me on the uh
laughing gas [__] tremendous they had
a great day
i'm california i want to thank ziki and
i want to thank the ice cream shop for
making it possible for me
to have my own weed i wish i would have
had it five [__] years ago
i gotta tell you it's great [__]
reefer and i'm not trying to blow smoke
up your ass no pun intended but it is
[__] pretty good goddamn reefer
uh you know i have had the joy of
getting i've been getting high again at
night
[__] right after i drink that [__]
kikimo tea i [__] go outside and i
i roll a joint and i smoke half of it
and i was telling joe from ice cream
shop
that i pretty much come close to passing
out
because in the mornings i think about
like what the [__] happened last night
all right i played the guitar
i watched whatever but it's like
oh [__] i talked to lee last night oh
[__] i talked to
lazaro last night that's my uncle so you
know it's been great
so i'm i'm happy i took the break i
needed it you know i was telling mike
that
i wasn't getting high throughout the day
anymore i i want to
you know tell you that i was chasing a
dragon all day
i was getting high in the morning then
the rest of the day was just [__]
you know yeah i'm high i know you're not
[__] high no you're not [__] high
so
it was great now i don't do that [__]
all day and at night i
get [__] blasted just a half a number
i put the [__] number out i bring it
in i got a little hiding spot
and every night at 11 o'clock i'm
outside smoking my little half a number
and uh thank god thank god i did it my
teeth are
better you know you're old when your
teeth are starting to turn gray that's
when you know
you're [__] old but i'm all right the
stitches are starting to come out
it's great every 10 minutes you spit out
a [__] piece of
yarn or whatever the [__] they put the
dispensable whatever the [__] they call
it disposable stitches
but at least the infection's going away
and uh i got to go back on the 26th it
was a [__] nightmare all right
thinking about it afterwards what he did
to my mouth last monday
he put the cocaine on my mouth right
let's take the i told him give me the
best whatever you got the noriega [__]
the [__] uh pablo escobar stuff
he put it on my gums and i tell you
you're supposed to wait like 10 or 15
minutes like go away
i put the earphones on i'm listening to
ac dc power range the next thing you
know
i open my eyes and he's coming at me
with a [__] i'm like whoa
i go okay it's starting already i
figured the thing was [__] dried
[__] no he was like an octopus this
[__] had needles in every
[__] hand
and he was popping him everywhere but
nothing nothing
hits you like a needle in the roof of
your [__] mouth that was
the most uncomfortable thing i've ever
gone through [__] in my life i mean
i'd rather get [__] in the ass at this
point
than put a [__] needle in the top the
roof of your [__] mouth that was
i was just sitting there like when does
this [__] end so i'm gonna tell him
when i go back on the 26 listening guy
it's a week from today i'm gonna tell
him listen you gotta relax
on me that [__] gave me [__] like
nightmares it was like watching the
exorcist when you attend
i [__] couldn't sleep for like two
[__] nights i was supposed to give
blood since wednesday
last week i finally went this morning
thank [__] god because
i haven't given the blood the [__]
need all the needles he gave me on
[__] monday just [__] my dream up
i was like i was like [__] duchess
for like two [__] days after that so
i gotta talk to this [__] dentist but
anyway
the main topic today that everybody want
to hear from me about was um cuba
name of this episode is viva [__]
cuba you understand me
now i don't have an opinion on what's
going on in cuba right now i'm still
trying to get the picture from my
relatives and whatnot
of what's really going on and one got
the [__] cubans going but what do you
expect
62 [__] years no food i think they
ran out of vaccines they got not nothing
nothing down there so i'm gonna tell you
my story with cuba
and then you make up your own [__]
decision on where i [__] stand
okay i was born in havana cuba 1963.
if you ask me what i remember from cuba
nothing i remember my dad holding me
and we were looking at a beach whether
it was valero i don't know what beach it
was
i'd love to tell you but i don't and
they're both dead
so i remember seeing a picture my mother
had a picture in her
picture things of a house in cuba
with a car in front of it and me my mom
and my dad
were holding hands that's the only
[__] picture of me
that i don't even know what the [__] the
picture is in the garbage or something
now i have no idea
we migrated to [__] new jersey
migrated to new york whatever the [__]
new york city new jersey my dad died
when i was three we lived in union city
then from there we moved to new york
all my life when i was a kid my mom did
a good job with me or raising me
but she did have hatred not
she's a disliked not it bothered her
she had hatred for the castro regime
hatred hatred everybody around my mother
had hatred but they were first
generation
pre-revolutionary people so they were
there
they felt it if you ever you know what
i'll do is hopefully
either this week or next week i'll get
rudy and we'll do a [__]
zoom and rudy like i've had
countless lunches with rudy we used to
go to a cuban spot in burbank called
porto's
countless conversations with rudy his
[__] hate
for cuba and the castro regime
are [__] unbelievable rudy sarzo
is the sweetest man i have ever met in
my life i mean and i tell you this
with confidence and sincerity
i love rudy sagero and we became
friends through podcasting and mutual
friends and we started doing lunches
and i got to tell you something he has
never said a negative word about
anybody or any situation at all
he even likes the osbournes you know
sharing the whole i mean
he's a great guy like that he has
nothing bad to say about anybody
but i will tell you something about rudy
his hatred for cuba
runs [__] deep he refuses to go back
he refuses to be a part of anything
he said that there's a heavy metal uh
contingency growing in cuba there's a
lot of like young heavy mettlers and he
wishes he could reach out to them and
help him
but he can't that's the same type of
people i grew up with
they had a [__] hatred for cuba
now that was me growing up my mother
died
in november of 79. so my mother missed
the marielle
harbor thing by a [__] contact like
it was like a [__] [__] hair
if she would have lasted three more
months she would have seen cuba open up
and when that happened you know it was a
sigh of relief a lot of people came over
a lot
not the right people came over a lot of
people that were in jail and whatnot
and they came up here and created havoc
but i remember marielle and i remember
talking to those people
and i remember being in san francisco in
85 and
meeting a whole new set of cubans and
they
were all from marielle i was part of a
little click there i was i would i would
sell
drugs with them whatever travelers
checks i was the only one who knew
english so
i would talk to them a lot that was when
my mother died in 79
i was i everything cuban i pushed it
away like the food i was like i'm not
gonna eat it unless my mom makes it
that's how much
pain i was in after my mom died but in
i started eating cuban food again like
in 83. my boycott lasted like four years
let's not [__] get carried away here
my boycott ended when i came back from
colorado
in february of 84. i missed cuban food
and i started eating it again
but i didn't have real contact with
cubans again in 84 i had contact with my
uncle
i had contact with my godfather we
didn't really talk about the cuban
situation
it was until 85 when i got to san
francisco that i learned
what communism really was what was going
on in cuba how
you know you had a [__] stand every
sunday you had to go to a
downtown cuba don't quote me on this
where
you had to go down there and stand for
10 hours
and people would be watching you and
fidel would talk like address the
country
on sundays or something like that and
you had a [__]
stand [__] pay attention
and clap and people were watching you
if you didn't clap that meant you
weren't paying attention
and that you were daydreaming they
[__] throw you in jail they'd pull
you out of there
they'd pull you out of the [__]
circle you know i mean
if you don't uh you know they don't tell
you
you guys remember when i had you all
romero with rogan
you don't tell them you want to play
baseball
they tell you what you're going to play
from what how you built
you know what what sizes you are how big
you are
what you know what your parents do they
they decide on that
for you you don't tell them like i want
to be a musician no you're going to be
an engineer
what yeah you're going to be an outer
space engineer holy [__]
half those guys i was selling drugs with
on the corner
all i had like big time positions in
cuba they were all [__] like
big things in cuba but
the cuban government stripped them of
everything when they left they came here
with the [__] on their [__] back
that's it you know the cubans that i
grew up with had all escaped cuba
before they they got their money taken
and their homes and all this [__] taken
from them
so for me i don't
i didn't really understand the full
spectrum of it until 1985
to like talk to those cubans and they
were telling me like if you don't go to
work one day
you [__] get put in jail you know
[__] like that like i
i was like what the [__] i didn't know
that was what communism was i was too
busy getting high
and [__] living it i had no [__]
idea so that made me start thinking then
i moved to boulder and when i moved to
boulder was where i met
like a cuban professor at the university
of colorado and
he was he taught like history or
something and when i found out he was
cuban i
i reached out to him you know i went to
his class and we spoke a little bit and
we would get coffee whatever and he
would talk to me about
the politics and how the because his
his perspective was
the pros and cons of communism like he
had pros and cons
he was like a son of a revolutionary
it's like my parents and he was like
wait a second they were a little extreme
he goes i'm looking at the pros and cons
the pros are
it's a great medical system a free
education
uh you know there's so many little
things that you say wow i wish they did
that in the united states
but no matter what they give you they
can't
give you freedom which is the main thing
that we need so
what are we talking about here if you
don't give me freedom to think
or freedom to express myself or to think
on my own i don't want to be an engineer
i want to play the [__] guitar and
let my head grow long
and stop cutting my fingernails and [__]
how about that that's what i want to
[__] do
so just that thing right there that
bothers me a little bit
i didn't have after you know and through
boulder and whatnot
i didn't really have that cuban thing
going
i did have a friend in boulder named
danny feebles and madeleine feebles
i'm still tight with them i talked to
danny this weekend on facebook
uh they were born in cuba and
they still had family going back and
forth in fact their mom
was spending half a year in [__] cuba
you know
she liked it that much i don't think she
liked the communism side of it that much
but she liked the island you know and
she would just go back for six months
and visit and mix in
with the people and then come back and
zip the [__] out of there i don't think
they really like
cuban americans they don't like cuban
americans down there
so mike that whole cuban thing was gone
from my life
until 2009. in 2009 i went to an
audition in malibu
and i saw this landing like a rock and
the ocean the way it looked and i go
wait a second
on the way to the audition i saw it and
i go [__]
i've been here before and um when i got
to the audition
i started thinking how i was there
before was i there with terry was i
there with another friend i go oh my god
i used to go there with my uncle
when i was a kid in 73 72 74
i would fly to california for a week
stay with my uncle and then he would
take me to disneyland and sea world and
we would go to malibu and have lunch and
he'd show me all different places
but i still remember us going there like
fishing one day
like we brought fishing rods and he had
a break from work
and we went there to go fishing so on
the way back i actually pulled over on
that rock and i actually called my uncle
after not talking to him
for 25 years i didn't talk to my uncle
from 1984
to 2009 almost to the date
of the 24 25 years it was like 24
and three-quarter months i just dialed
his number
and he answered it and i told him that i
was sorry for what i had done in 84
and that i had changed i lived in
california now
and i started hooking up with my uncle
we started doing lunches once a week
and through my uncle he reconnected me
with my sister
which was [__] great you know so
me and my sister opened up communication
like in 2010
and we didn't speak from like 1979
to 2010 we didn't know how to
communicate with one another
we didn't know what was going on the
family i blacked out from the family
after that
situation from my uncle i knew he was
going to tell my family what i did and i
was embarrassed you know so
he actually told my family in cuba what
i did
my situation they weren't mad at me they
knew i was young
that i had made a mistake and when i
hooked up with my uncle he pushed me
towards my sister
i started talking to my sister right
away started sending her money
we would talk every 10 days life was
great
you know we i was planning on figuring
out how to get down there
to see them and then a short time after
that while i was talking to my
sister on the phone from cuba
one day i got a call from the improv i
look at my phone i go why is the improv
call me i'm a comedy store guy
it's the [__] improv and i love the
improv and i love the hollywood improv
it's the hollywood improv
and when i answered the phone it was
like four in the afternoon and it was
one of the managers from the improv and
they're like listen
i don't mean to bother you but your
family is here and i go what
it's for in the afternoon what are you
talking about and they're like your
family's here
family i got no family and they're like
hold on and they put
a girl on the phone and she's like coco
i'm
emmy alfonso i'm your [__] cousin i'm
diente's daughter uh i'm your you know
your cousin blah blah blah we're here
me my brother my father
my stepmother we're all in california we
came to record now i'm in burbank
and we saw your name at the improv on
the thing so we pulled over and they
gave us your number
do you have a show tonight and i'm like
absolutely i have to show at the comedy
store
let's go out to dinner and they go no no
we're gonna do dinner but we'll meet you
at the comedy store then we'll get
together after that i was like fine so
my cousin
my male cousin my
uncle my aunt and my uncle from l.a
came to the improv and then we went to
canters on fairfax afterward
and we just talked we talked from like
maybe
10 30 to maybe 2 30 in the morning three
in the morning like i was out late with
them
and we were just talking i think i cried
three times while i was at the table
because they were telling me how they
grew up like they were musicians
and uh their father was a musician
diente is a musician
he's got a band called
something with santeria or something and
they do like uh
soul music it's great they they're great
they do their own thing
the male cousin eki does like rock
with a [__] heavy metal tune and you
know he's got the long dreads and [__]
and emmy alfonso was the female she's
the next chadei she's the one that went
through south to southwest
and did all the stuff but they were
telling me horror shows
like they became musicians because
my uncle became a musician and my aunt
their sister rosita my mother's sister
rosita rosita
is the sister that my mother was getting
raped when my mother walked up
and stabbed the guy so rosita has always
felt a certain guilt about my mother
so while i was talking to my sister i
would also i also started calling my
aunt rosita
and i would get her perspective but
the perspective from my cousins about
cuba at the time
they were telling me like the first time
they heard led zeppelin iv
like that they lost their minds it came
in a cassette
they couldn't put the cassette in their
house they had to bury the cassette
in the [__] front yard under a tree
bury it really good because if you got
found
having a [__] led zeppelin cassette
or a beatles cassette
or a [__] ac dc cassette they throw
you in jail
it's anti-fucking it's against the law
so think about your freedoms real quick
here you can't listen you can listen to
the music
they approve you can't listen to music
from the outside [__] world so just
there alone
like just that alone and yes over the
years
the only reason why eki and emmy became
musicians and form the band
is because how deep my aunt and my
sister are into the government
okay so think about what i'm telling you
right now so that makes them [__]
communist
like my uncle went in 79 he went to a
park and he was arguing with some guy
about baseball
and some other guy said that he heard my
uncle say that fidel was a [__]
holy [__] they threw him in jail and he
went in front of the [__] judge and
the judge said we'll sentence him next
week but it's going to be in the [__]
20 to 30 year range
two days later my aunt actually walked
into the jail
told one of the guards to open the door
and they let my uncle out of [__]
jail it was because of a political
you know greg fitzsimmons is going to go
to cuba last april
during the pandemic i think yeah during
the pandemic he was supposed to go to
cuba with his son
for a graduation present my aunt was
actually going gonna pick him up at the
[__] airport
pick him up and take him to like my
uncle's [__] uh my cousin's
bar and havana and the [__] whole
thing
the pandemic ruined it i had [__] cr
greg
tightened up with my aunt my aunt was
gonna do everything for him my aunt's
got that type of juice
in cuba the killer for me was
i had spoken from to my sister from 2010
and now it was about 2016.
i became tight with my sister and i
talked to my sister a lot
and one day i said [__] it i'm i know
exactly
what i'm gonna do i called her up one
day
the same way i had been doing i was like
on a program with i think i would call
every tuesday or something like at a
certain time
and i would send money once a month you
know in the beginning of the month
let me put it through this way when my
mother was alive i know my mother was
sending money
and they were getting like i don't know
maybe 80
of the money now when i send money
they get like 20 so if i send my sister
500 bucks
she gets like 100 of that the government
takes the rest
just so you guys know what's going on
because a lot of you is like what's
going on
let me tell you what the [__] is going
on this is what's going on so
i love my sister guys i i [__] love
my sister just the thought of me having
a sister growing up
gave me something to live for like i
have a sister that i'm gonna see someday
was i tight with her as a kid until my
mother died
we spoke whenever my mother called cuba
which was
three times a [__] week if i was
around my mom would go home
come here say hello to your sister and i
would say to my
talk to my sister about whatever you
know my sister
if i'm 58 my sister's 63
you know so she was always older you
know
when my mother died obviously i didn't
my mother had her
her number and her [__] head nothing
was written my mom didn't have a phone
book
so that was the reason why i didn't call
my sister but i always thought about my
sister
and i always said to myself how would i
act if i had my sister living here in
the house
so that was why like my mom always
taught me to be cool with women like my
mom had so many women around her
i learned to be cool with women but i
got cooler
when i realized i had a sister so when
something was going on
with a girl i would go whoa how would i
feel if that was my sister
so it made me a better [__] man in a
way
and then i had a daughter and it even
helped me more but
knowing that i had a sister at least
gave me
something to work around and i tell you
this because what i'm about to tell you
is gonna
[__] you up so i love my sister
one day i'm getting ready to call and i
figured out what i'm gonna do
i go i'm gonna call my sister
i've saved some money i'm gonna invite
her
and her husband to fly to new jersey
i'm gonna fly to new jersey with my wife
and my daughter
i'm gonna meet them in jersey pick them
up in newark
take them to the best hotel i can in the
city
and then give them like a [__] tour
give them a tour where my mother's bar
was
where we lived in new york city where we
lived in north bergen take it to the
cemetery
you know take it to eat introduce it to
my wife
introduced it to my daughter you know
that was the plan
so i was all enthusiastic you know when
you were [__] into you know when you
wake up and you're like yeah today is
the day
like i was all sight that i had finally
put this [__] plan in my head
and i called my sister and i go magaly
can i talk to you and she's like what's
going on i go listen
my sister's buck wild she's like my mom
she would always answer the phone and
call me a [__] and [__]
oh yeah you know she'd always say [__]
to me
so my sister's wild so i call up i'm
like what's going on she's like what's
going on you [__] queer whatever the
[__] she calls me and i'm like nothing
i gotta talk to you about something i go
listen i've been thinking i talked to my
wife
and i got the green light listen how
about
we start looking at plane ticket prices
and
we fly to newark and i show you like i
told you guys take it to the bar
take it to the cemetery give you the
[__] dinora tour
take it to the bronx show you her
bookmaking operation take you to harlem
show you the book make and operate just
all the spots take it 113th
to where's the rider live you know just
i was going to give it a [__] tour
i'm not
i'm no [__] tour guide trust me if
you come to jersey don't call
me and say oh well take me around i
don't know nothing i know the city i
know what i know you know what i'm
saying like what i know about me i know
so i could have given her a great tour i
don't know nothing like if you come to
new york city tell me where do you go i
don't [__] know
go see the statue i don't know i don't
know where the [__] to take it
i just know what i know so i was gonna
take her all around
you know when you're excited and you're
[__] fired up and you're like
oh my god i came up with a great idea
and the idea just went flat
like when i asked her the line just went
beep and i'm like magaly and she's like
yeah
and i'm like so what do you think is
that a great idea
and she's like listen it's not gonna
happen
she goes i'm too old i'm too set in my
ways
and my husband can't do that
that's not even allowed he would lose
his job and his
and his pension and all this other [__]
and i'm like
are you [__] serious
so it kind of broke my heart because for
the last six years
i had been talking to her
and it was hard talking to my sister is
hard guys and i'm gonna tell you why
because she sounds like my mother one
and
two i've worked really hard to lift the
pain of my mother off me
i worked really hard when i opened up
the line of communication with her
she flipped my mother on me she flipped
it in a way she didn't know she was
doing it she did nothing wrong my sister
what she was doing was telling me what
she had gone through
you know like i didn't go through
anything like i you know like she's like
well
at least you got to spend time with her
i go so did you
till you were [__] six or seven and
then when my mom wanted to come back
you didn't want to come back to the
united states without a young age you
wanted to finish the school year
that's the only reason why my mom left
that my mom was going back and forth to
cuba like
people go to [__] san diego from l.a
you know like if we go down the shore in
jersey
you could just go back and forth in 63
64 65
after that things tightened up things
tightened up a lot
the other thing about my sister that i i
didn't like was
the day my mother died the week my
mother died
i had a pride i had to look for [__] i'm
not
listen i was a good burglar but i hate
going through your [__]
you know what i'm saying like i don't
like going through people's [__]
it's not my i've been with my wife for
20 years i never go through her [__] her
drawers her drawers
don't touch my [__] i'm one of those
guys i won't go through your [__] i
don't believe in that i don't like
reading your diary
i don't like none of that [__] so i
never went through my mom's [__]
until the day she died i had to look for
[__]
i found this [__] letter from cuba
that was dated like
august of 79 that was one of the worst
things
i had ever read in my life
and it was all towards my mother and it
was like three letters
from three different family members her
grandmother
my sister and one of her brothers
it was the worst thing i had ever read
in my life
because it was all [__] i knew one
thing for sure about my mother
my mother was very generous very
generous
and every [__] week whenever she'd
hit the horses or
she'd have a great week at the bar i
would go with her
personally to [__] western union
personally personally she would make a
stop
at western union and [__] go in her
tit
and take out a lot of [__] cash and
send it to
her mom and my sister personally i know
this for a fact
i can't tell you how many western union
receipts
my mother had and i can't tell you how
many times i went to western union 4
to send money what happened was
when my mother lost a bar in 78 her
income went down
she took her savings and she was living
and investing off her savings which was
nothing she spent
you know if the mets played that was it
she bet the [__] mets
but she would send envelopes some money
to cuba and i i'm
telling you it was good money she was
sending down there
they wrote these [__] letters that my
mother was a piece of [__]
that the united states [__] you i mean
the letter was horrible
i basically took the letter i rip it up
i ripped it up
and i just dealt with my mother's death
i'm not gonna read this [__] no more
i'm not gonna talk to these [__]
people no more and i'm not gonna
so i asked my sister about those letters
like a year into our relationship
i go hey man i gotta ask you a question
i read a letter that you
sent my mother in 1979
talking about hate and [__] you and
everything she goes no
let me tell you what happened i go you
know
what the [__] happened that was a
horrible letter and she goes listen what
happened was
in those days the government was sitting
us down
and they were in the mid 70s
from the mid 70s to the point that the
marielle
[__] uh opening in 1980 whatever the
late 79
he goes my sister was telling me that
the fidel
regime was making them write hate mail
like it was [__] and i i remember
talking to rudy about this and rudy was
like yeah
like there's so many things fidel castro
did down there
there's so many [__] creepy things he
did down there but there was a point
where he was brainwashing them
to tell everybody like scientology like
to tell everybody in the united states
they suck
you don't want nothing from them [__]
them you know keep a
a united front cuban americans are no
good
so this is what was going on at the time
so you know when
i talked to my sister that day and she
told me she couldn't make the trip or
whatever
i go you know for the last six years
every time i talk to you
i get off the phone with you and i gotta
have [__] two cocktails not even
drink
that's how bad i feel every time i talk
to my sister
i was made to feel [__] guilty
because
i lived because i existed you know she
had no idea what i went through
like one day waking up and your mother's
dead you find the dead on the floor
and then a month later you got to move
in with your friends and then a month
later you hooked on [__] coke and
then a month later
i was you know i was just finding for
myself people always ask me well
in that time you never thought of
calling your family in cuba for what
what were they going to do for me they
were in cuba i was alone in jersey was i
going to pack up and move to [__]
cuba
they couldn't [__] help me they were
poorer than i was so
that was my you know everybody was like
oh you lost contact yeah i lost contact
with everybody
nobody wanted to talk to me i was a
[__] kid even my godfather it was
people that would just you know
that's just the way life is and i
understood it i didn't get mad i mean
that that's the way life is
but i'm [__] cuban so i feel so when
i got off the phone my sister that dab
we had it was not a disagreement there
was no yelling there was no curse there
was no screaming but obviously my
feelings were [__] hurt
i'm up here trying you're bitching that
you don't have a [__] i would have
gave it
whatever she wanted i would have gave
her just
so she wouldn't feel the way she did
but her communism roots
wouldn't let her [__] do it so that's
why
for the last week when you people have
been hit me up
asking me about cuba or what the [__]
going on
i had to say something on this podcast
to tell you what my feelings are about
cuba
and my feelings about cuba is this plain
and [__] simple
i called my uncle twice this week at
night so i could come on this podcast
and at least be a little knowledgeable
with you about what's going on
and he was telling me that what happened
is what's going on
the the [__] levee broke you ever
hear that song by led zeppelin when the
levee breaks got no place to stay
the levee broke you know you get sick
and tired of getting sick and tired
there's no food there's no vaccines
there's no this there's no that
that's it you know you're looking
through a lens of how people are living
and you're [__] on an island
stuck with three eggs a month that's
what they get they get like three eggs a
month
a half a pound of [__] coffee you get
like [__]
four pieces of bread and that's what you
got to live off a [__] month
that's the reality it's the [__] cuba
right there
so it's just a million people
that uh you know now [__] kovitz
really going to spread now the
government's tightening up on them
they've gotten venezuela involved and as
well and double agents are on the
streets
telling people asking people questions
then they take them and they beat them
up
it's it's a [__] night man it's scary
and everybody's waiting for the us
government to [__] uh
you know the the mayor of miami let's
bomb
[__] cuba you can't bomb [__] cuba
if you bomb cuba we'll start a [__]
war i mean you don't think this frazzles
me
that 90 miles away think about that
90 miles away
is a [__] enemy and we've had that
there
for [__] 62 [__] years right there
right down the block right down the
block if you live in la
it's closer few it's closer than san
diego
san diego is 100 miles away from l.a
[__] havana is 90 miles away from
miami give or take a few [__] miles
people swim it that's how close it is we
have an
enemy a [__] just
this thing did you ever think about it
we just have this thing
just laying there 90 miles away from us
you watch the [__] weather map
you see it and they'll talk to you about
haiti they'll talk to you about [__]
the couscous whatever the island is
uh kyokos caucus you know they'll talk
to you about the dominican republic and
puerto rico
but nobody gives a [__] about it's right
there they don't tell you the weather
but we try to hide it as much as we can
you know the hurricane is going through
cuba right now we don't stop and see
pictures of cuba
nobody cares no listen they're a
communist [__] country we have to
care
they're our enemy and they're 90 [__]
miles away now
there's a flip to this coin that's the
joey diaz flip
because you have to think about this too
look at all the people
that are involved in this sos thing if
you go on social media
you got everybody [__] sending on sos
is for cuba
and i love it and i'm with you but do me
a favor
when those people come over here because
that's the only way
we're also going to go mexico puerto
rico
[__] no you want to come to the major
leagues
you want to come to the united states so
the next time you people are [__]
you know [__] cubans this this
remember
when they come here i don't want to hear
you [__] crying
all right this sword's got two edges to
it so when they come here when they get
here in about a year when this thing
blows up like
because that's what's going to happen
there's only three [__] scenarios i
see
us bombing [__] cuba right i was
going to war with [__]
well there's two scenarios i see the
united states saving cuba which
the other scenario i don't i don't see
that happening
joe biden has enough trouble walking up
and down the stairs
without [__] thinking about cuba you
know i don't see
kamala harris [__] thinking about
cuba
you know i mean even black lives matter
supported
the cuban government so obviously they
don't know their [__] history
because what the [__] what the [__] it
was a slave [__] play did you not
watch amistad
[__] cuba was a [__] slave
transport
place the reason i am how i am is
because i'm half a [__] slave i have
slave blood i mean i have
african blood in me i did the 23 and me
i ain't [__] i i did it
i did it i see what's in my [__]
blood you know
if you any of you watch you know the
cellular crew story on netflix
her skin was too dark to enter a talent
talent contest did you know that did you
guys even [__] know that that celia
almost did not become celia
because her skin was too [__] darker
than that there is no place
ever as racist as cuba is
and if you guys got a problem with that
if you want me to prove it to you
i'll have my uncle [__] call into
we'll do a [__] i don't think he
knows how to zoom my uncle
but i have him do a call and he'll tell
you how he went to matanzas
in 1944 to play baseball
and they told him to get the [__] out of
here
that he was too [__] dark to play
baseball
and they made a dog piss on him until
this day he's like that's the luckiest
thing that ever happened to me that dog
pissing on me
the luck it brought me he thought it was
a lucky day but in reality if you talk
to him you could feel the pain
my uncle's dark-skinned even though my
mom and
you know we're like [__] cats every
generation you come back a different the
reason why they call me coco isn't
because i did tons of coke
it was a name given to me by my father
because my skin was so white it was like
the inside of a [__] coconut
so i don't know how the [__] you guys
came up with that [__]
theory that you're going to back the
cuban government because they've been
great to know they have not been great
to
african-americans as a matter of [__]
fact i'm going to tell you what a lady
said to me one time in 1985
in fort lee new jersey this panamanian
woman told me one time she goes you know
why that's going on in cuba
that's a punishment from god that's a
punishment from god
she goes let me tell you something for
years she goes i want the cube as a
young girl
it was disgusting she goes it was it was
worse than harvey weinstein worse than
epstein's [__] mansion
it was horrible they were [__]
animals
they were [__] young girls you know
20 years ago when all those
americans started going to cuba and all
those canadians
you know why they go to cuba right in
men's group
because they go down there to [__] 15
year old girls and 16 year old
prostitutes
you guys know that right i hope you do
know that
that when you see a men's group going
down to cuba it's the [__] 16 year old
hookers
they're hot to trot and they're down
there on their malikong
and they're selling that ass for [__]
ten dollars [__]
usa these old [__] white perverts go
down there and get their helmets
polished by 16 year old [__] girls
it's been a den of [__] disgust for
years
you know that story i always tell you
guys about the superman of cuba
read that [__] story read that go
online
and look up the superman at cuba read
the full 45 minute [__] story
on how planes would pack up just to go
see that
guy's big dick [__] rape some chick
that's what you paid for
to see some chick that didn't want a big
[__] dick in her
you know that's what you paid for so
that's what cuba was about
so she goes well cuba is serving right
now is a punishment from god
for how [__] crazy that play i mean
she said she was there like in 1940
1950 and it was just a [__] people
were [__] chickens
and animals and it was like you know
like 42nd street was for me as a kid
you went and saw the hookers and [__]
sex world and all that [__]
that's what cuba was yes it was a
beautiful island
and yes there was tons of italians down
there and casinos and all that stuff
but read books like havana nocturne read
you know
there was a little book i found on cuba
i don't know what the [__] happened to
over the years it was my favorite
[__] book
i ever read on cube it was about jose
marti
and the slaves and you know it just gave
you it showed you the corruption
the level of corruption you know when
fidel came in there
fidel came in there as a savior
the people brought him in there they
wanted fidel because batista was such a
[__] horrible dictator horrible
just like i told you as a kid i grew up
with martin perez
and up to the [__] sixth grade martin
perez was my friend and one day he just
disappeared into the witness relocation
because his dad was batista's driver
and cubans were hunting down to shoot
him right in [__] union city and in
north bergen they were going to kill him
in north bergen
that's how deep the hatred was for the
batista regime
so think about it it's like having a
girlfriend that [__]
[__] your brother [__] your dad tastes
your stuff
cheats on you with everybody you hate
her
and all sudden you welcome another lady
into your life
that seems great comes on to you [__]
great everything's great in the
beginning
and after the honeymoon you get zapped
that you're a [__] socialist or
whatever a communist
how would you [__] feel that's
exactly what castro did to them
so they've been getting beat up down
there for close to 90 [__] years
they've been getting beat up down there
so eventually the scene [__] breaks
the people you see on the streets
are younger generations of people who
have been there
since they were getting [__] beat up
cuba's got no rules you know when you
hear about
crimes of war and all this stuff done by
all these mus
multioce and all these [__] people
they blame columbus for crimes of war
you gotta start looking at cuba for that
[__] they're doing some horrible things
down there
so i hope that eventually somebody
[__] helps them
but the only thing i see to get back to
that that
scenario i see this ending
as marielle i see this i see
300 boats going down there and
diaz whatever his name is canal just
saying listen
if you don't like it [__] leave
and all the miami people who have family
down there and loved ones that they want
to leave
or just have to shoot down there and go
get them and i don't think they're going
to give them up that easy either i think
it's going to be a [__] you know
so that's what i see from this result i
don't know if this is going to be
what's going to happen i don't have a
[__] uh
a crystal ball in front of me i'm just
telling you that
i don't see our government bail on cuba
i don't see it at all there's a couple
people raising their hand i mean the
mayor of miami just
said this bomb miam just bombed cuba
that's great but
how many innocent people were there you
know let's get those people out of there
and then we could bomb those commie
bastards or whatever the [__] i mean i i
don't know
that's the only answer i got for you
guys that's that that's it that's my
opinion on [__] cuba
that's it i wish i had more for you i
wish i could offer more
you know i'm just telling you my story
the things that i've heard the people
i've rubbed shoulders with
their feelings toward and my feelings
towards it it's a communist [__]
place
my family has been torn apart by it you
know i don't have
a majority of my family because in
reality they're communist
when i you know i've seen my cousins and
my uncles
maybe four other times in california i
spent i think
thanksgiving 2018 with them
in studio city
we're there for hours when i see my
family
from cuba we get along we hug we eat
we have a great time but we never talk
politics
it's not like i'm asking them about
their situation they're not asking me in
my mind we're just family
whatever they do they do it's got
nothing to do with me i wish them luck
i love my cousins i love emmy and i love
eki
i don't care if that commie bastards
it's just it's the way it is
you know what i'm saying i love them i
overlooked that it's like if they were a
junkie
you know when i was a junkie people had
love for me even though i was a junkie i
feel the same way
with them so i hope you guys understand
where i'm coming from
and you guys accept what i'm telling you
the only way this is going to end
is by us going to pick up our loved ones
and i know that like
llamas the ufc fighter and whatever we
want to talk
if anybody wants to do a a talk or a
zoom
or whatever i'm willing to do it you
know with
anybody cuban just to help you guys
understand
that we i don't know i don't know what
the [__] to think but
i see this going out the way marielle
did
that's my [__] story before we leave
i want to talk to you about something
again
i want to talk thank you for the support
on laughing guys ziki
and the ice cream shop but i also want
to talk to you about friday
friday was a special day for me not
because of
the laughing gas it was also a special
day for me because
of my 30 years in comedy and even though
i'm not doing comedy at the present time
doesn't mean that i did comedy 29 and a
half years
it meant that i did the work
i'm i was very proud on friday i was a
little sad that i wasn't doing stand-up
that night
you know i don't want to do it right now
um it's not in my [__] forecast uh
i'd much rather just be a dad
right now i enjoy doing the podcast i
enjoy doing the patreon
stand up i got a little problem with
right now you know
between the pandemic and all that stuff
i could blame it on that but
between you and me i just don't feel
like doing it and i've accepted it
already
for a couple weeks i had a problem with
it why wouldn't i love
something that i did for 30 years but
i came to grips with it i spoke to
somebody you know
i spoke to a therapist i'm still talking
to her i talked to her again tomorrow at
9 30 in the [__] morning and uh
i'm okay with it i'm fine i'm happy
doing what i'm doing
and one night when i look at the clock
and i'm like tonight's tonight i'm gonna
do stand-up you
you [__] will be the first to
know but
30 years doing stand-up holy [__]
and i'll tell you what it really wasn't
30 years of stand-up
it was 30 years
for me to get my [__] together that's
what this whole thing has been
you know friday i got up friday morning
i
you know i go to the gym i write my
journal like
it was like three pages of journaling
friday
because it was so much to comprehend and
to understand
this wasn't about me becoming a star
this wasn't about me being in movies
this wasn't about me
this had nothing to do with the 30 last
years have been joey diaz's
getting his [__] together tour that's
all this was
it was a start from 1963 i lived from
to 1991 lost
i had it together until i was 16 my
mother passed
and i became a [__] uh you know a
drug addict and i was lost
you know comedy helped me find my way
back
it taught me who i was it taught me what
i could do
it taught me that i wasn't scared of
hard work i wasn't scared of what
anybody [__] thought
or whatever whatever negativity you had
if you don't want to clap you don't have
to clap you know
it's a hard thing being a [__] comic
not everybody could do it
it's very tough your skin has to be
tough
and i did it i conquered all my fears
and i moved forward regardless of what
the [__] was going on
and i'm very proud of that the last 30
years and guess
what it ended with me coming back to new
jersey
getting the dignity back getting my
pride back to being able to come back
here
and hold my head high that's what the
last 30 years was about
and i'm very proud of this you know i'm
gonna call my book agent on monday and
talk to him and try to tell him that
what i want for this book
is the last 30 years this is what the
mean potatoes is anything else is the
story of my mother
and we're just writing to [__] you
know to be a big book like my jimmy page
book
i don't want to do that i'd rather just
focus on the 30 years of comedy what i
learned
what i did what i didn't do and the
struggles
to let people know that it was [__]
great
and i wouldn't have changed anything if
i could change one thing
about the last 30 years would be two
things
i don't care about the junk i don't care
about the coke listen
it took me to where i am today it made
me the man i am today
but there was two things now i forgot
what the [__] two things were
this is what happens uh there was two
[__] things
i wish that i hadn't beaten myself up
like i did don't beat yourself up
enjoy the ride you're gonna have good
nights and bad nights in this in the
beginning there's a lot of [__] bad
nights you know
yesterday a couple guys hit me up on you
know online
and hey man congratulations on the 30.
i've been in it for seven
congratulations on the 30 i've been in
it for four
you know i've been in there for two a
couple guys hit me up like that and it
meant the world to me
because it brought me back for a minute
seven what was i doing at seven years
you know oh
[__] i was at the store four years what
was i doing oh [__] i was just about to
go on the road you know
two years oh i wasn't doing dick i was
just doing like
you know eight spots a month and
snorting coke and telling girls i'm a
comic but i really wasn't a comic i was
just a [__] open mic mutt you know
there was two things that i took away
from this one i wish i wouldn't have
beat myself up as
much i really beat myself up i got to
the point where i hated myself
and the coke you know when you look at
my face and i have all these scars it's
scarring it's it's me
picking it's like somebody [__]
slicing at their skin
i hated who the [__] i was when i was
doing that [__]
but all that aside i was don't beat
yourself up
whether you're gonna become a comic
whether you'd be gonna become
a guitar player a [__] a band leader
an artist whatever the [__] you want to
do in that world
a don't beat yourself up do not beat
yourself up it's not worth it
you're gonna get to your destination
obviously you're beating yourself up
because you love what you do and you
don't want to [__] up don't beat
yourself up you're going to get to that
destination
if you're thinking like that that you're
beating yourself up that means you love
something there's nothing wrong with
loving something
just don't beat yourself up and number
two i wish i was a little bit more
patient in the beginning
i think my first 10 years i was very
impatient
and again if you love something that
much you're going to get to that
destination don't worry about it you're
going to get there
it's just gonna take some time i was a
little impatient
not in the sense of
being a pig or whatever i think i was
more
impatient and wanting to get there
you're gonna get there you're gonna get
there
when the time is right you're gonna get
there it's like taking a bus from
penn station or port authority to north
carolina
sometimes the book the bus takes eight
hours
sometimes it takes ten and a half hours
you know what
you're gonna get there be patient don't
beat yourself up
stay true to yourself and anything that
you choose in this life would be [__]
phenomenal listen this thing this
[__] microphone and this bricks on
the wall
they saved my life they let me know i
could do something for years
i searched for i wanted to be a mason i
wanted to work at the stock market
i want to be an estimator i wanted to be
a [__] economic major
i didn't want to do [__] i didn't want
to do [__] i wanted to crack jokes
smoke pot in front of a [__] brick
wall and have [__]
people boo me or clap that's it that's
how easy it is
there was nothing else to it i didn't
think about movies i didn't think about
tv shows
i didn't think about podcasts i went
into this with all my heart and i'm
happy
i'm very happy that i became the man
that i became
before my mom died a week before she
died she told me i just want you to grow
up to be a man
i don't care how you do it i don't care
what you do if you're a [__] janitor
be the best janitor on the force
and that's exactly what i did i was the
best that i could be
for the time i did it for how long i
could do it i'm very proud of that
so i'm happy that you guys still follow
me i'm happy that i still have your
support
and i'm happy that you're having a good
time and you're enjoying your life and
you're still enjoying what i got to say
because it's from the heart and it's
always been from the [__] heart
so i appreciate you [__] thank
you for supporting me
thank you for asking me about cuba thank
you for letting me tell my story
and thank you for the last 30 years i
hope the next 30 years are [__] great
also in comedy
i love you [__] thank you for
watching i'll be back wednesday tip top
magoo
uh patreon still alive the album of the
week
laughing gas we got plenty of it it's
limited right now the big [__] uh
push is gonna be in august that's when
the new growth comes out it's gonna be
stronger
and better than what it is now so i
appreciate you [__] with all my
heart
thank you and now for a word from my
[__] sponsors jack
all right you bad [__] thank
you very much for listening to viva
cuba today cuba libre whatever the [__]
i told you it was called in the
beginning who the [__] knows anymore
the joint is brought to you by cbd line
today the best
when it comes to cbd i've been with them
for about two to three years
and they've always [__] surprised the
[__] out of me they're that good
whether it's the gummy bears they got
these new gummy gummy bears with
melatonin in them [__] tremendous
they got the hemp flower they got the
capsules they got the roll-on
they got the extra strength cream they
got bath balls what does cbd line
not do for you it's tremendous okay
whether you have anxiety
a little pain do me a favor go to cbd
lion
and read read up on what they have to
offer the cbd cbn
cbd what's going on and how it could
work with you
and which one of their products can help
you with your problem
go to cbdlion.com right now
read the third party lab results and
i'll tell you what
you could keep going to a liquor store
and buying cbd or you could buy the best
with cbd lion
do me a favor press in code joey or
church and i'm going to get you 20 off
your order delivered right to your house
that's what cbd lion does okay
so do me a favor next time you [__]
want to [__] around with cbd
you're just throwing away your money by
buying it off one of those [__]
ripoff artists
cbd line is the way to go go to cbd lion
read the third party lab results
pressing code joey or church and get 20
off cbd lion this is the smart way to go
the joint is also brought to you by
manscaped
why do i love manscape because listen i
want all your dicks
and all your monkeys to look [__]
tremendous the best thing they can
listen you can look like a [__]
moutage like me i'm no [__]
richie gear but let me tell you
something the area on my dick and my
ball sack looks tremendous even if my
dick looks like an odd bark
i'll tell you what it's still beautiful
why
because i stay on top with manscaped
manscape
gets it [__] nice and smooth my balls
are nice and smooth
my dick don't have that onion smell to
it when you have a lot of hair
you like you let your bush grow out a
lot it's not good for you
manscape has the answer for you manscape
just revealed
their fourth generation performance
package
that comes with a new lawnmower 4.0
trimmer
like i said in the beginning i could
give you a bunch of [__] but it's
still
skin safe technology the bottom line is
they're there to protect your balls and
that little [__] [__] i don't want it
to get hit but no [__] razor blades
even my long balls don't get caught in
these [__] gears
and the blades are sharp enough to cut
through [__] white hairs
and anybody who's got white hairs nose
they're [__] deadly
you set the length of your trim from one
to four if you're old school
they even made the light brighter for
you and added a travel lock and made it
[__] waterproof
that's how intense [__] manscape
wants
everybody to have their dicks and nut
sacks [__] clean
and they don't stop at your nuts there's
some of people going to be looking at
you from all angles okay
so you got to get the weed whacker trim
up your nose and your ears
with 9000 rpm motor this thing got
boogers
out of my nose that they've been in
there since 1981
i think i went to a ted concert that
year then you got my favorites in there
you got the crop preserver
an anti-chafing ball deodorant
tremendous and you've got the crop
reviver that's my real favorite
ball toner it tightens your nut sack up
to look like superman's nuts
[__] women will be kissing that
[__]
and when you get the performance package
they throw in a travel bag
and a pair of manscape boxes who's
better than you
nobody [__] manscape get 20
off and free worldwide shipping by going
to manscape.com
slash show if you don't have a [__]
manscape razor you should be shot and
[__] hung
you should be ashamed of yourself your
ball sack then you sit there i don't
have a date
nobody wants to date me because your
dick looks like a [__] junkyard you
filthy [__]
go to manscape.com right now put it in
code joey
and i'm going to get you 20 off 20 off
and free worldwide shipping that's a
deal and a half
on a monday morning it's summer how much
longer you're going to run around with
that [__] bush on your [__]
i even used my manscape on my [__]
knee to shave that
julius irving afro i had off my [__]
knee
manscape is the best no more stinky
hairs with manscape
again manscape.com joey
and i'm gonna get you 20 off and free
worldwide shipping
i want to thank cbd lion i want to thank
manscaped
but i want to thank you guys for having
my back on a monday morning
i love you [__] have a great
week and i'll see you wednesday
[Music]
it's all over the shouting [__]
go live your life
[Music]
so
you